so we've been given our first official  look at john week four in the form of a  newly released picture in this picture  we see him kneeling at some type of  altar perhaps as he's surrounded by  candles he may be paying his penalty or  he is confessing we don't have any  official confirmation for the title of  the movie however was teased by an actor  to be john wick chapter four hagerkiri  the release date for john rick chapter 4  was also delayed until early 2023 it is  currently set to debut on march 24th  2023. so what do you guys think of the  first look at john rick for any clues or  things you can break down from this  image that i haven't picked up on let me  know in the comments section below and  if you did enjoy this video please like  and subscribe and turn notifications on  to show your support thanks for watching